temporada de huracanes en tiempos de
pandemia un cóctel que agrava aún más la
situación de emergencia sanitaria y
económica en centroamérica por el kobe
19 el impacto de la tormenta tropical y
ota deja un reguero de devastación a su
paso que se suma a los impactos del
virus en una región donde la
vulnerabilidad de las personas y las
desigualdades eran ya alarmantes la
región ha sido golpeada por la pandemia
de kobe 19 que actualmente cuenta con
más de 260 mil casos registrados las
organizaciones humanitarias alertan
sobre un posible aumento de contagios
como consecuencia de los huracanes y el
hacinamiento en albergues donde hay unas
30.000 personas en nicaragua país de
entrada de la depresión tropical el
número de contagios roza los 6000 y
cuenta con al menos 159 muertos pero las
asociaciones médicas nicaragüenses han
insistido al gobierno en que muestre los
datos reales de la pandemia mientras que
en honduras las deficiencias del sistema
sanitario precarizaron el trabajo de la
primera línea de batalla contra la
enfermedad de los hospitales donde más
de 70 miembros del personal médico
fallecieron por el cob y 19 cifras del
pasado agosto son víctimas de un sistema
envío
a pelear una guerra sin los insumos
necesarios para poder tener
en la posibilidad de triunfar y el
salvador donde desde el inicio de la
pandemia se impusieron fuertes
restricciones de movilidad registran más
de 36.000 positivos guatemala es el país
con más decesos por la pandemia
centroamérica con casi 4.000 y suma más
de 115 mil contagios por su parte
colombia uno de los países más golpeados
en américa latina' sus islas caribeñas
de san andrés y providencia cuentan con
dos mil cuatro contagios pero las
infraestructuras han quedado totalmente
arrasadas por el huracán las
inundaciones y la falta de insumos que
dificultarán aún más la lucha contra la
pandemia